so in case you guys haven't noticed i
don't just make videos on architecture
anymore i'm a tech reviewer now so why
are you wearing a hat um because tech
reviewers wear hats
just the other day hp reached out and
they sent me some six shwag
and this kit it includes the uh hp
spectre 360 and the hp envy 7955e
printer and the hp u28 monitor so these
actually came at the perfect time
because i was already looking for a
device i could do multiple things
like work and sketch so yeah i just
figured it'd be a really nice way for me
to share my thoughts on convertible
laptops so in this video i'm going to
share my experience with the 16-inch
version of the spectre x 360. i'm going
to talk about the product i'm going to
talk about the design ergonomics specs a
little bit about software compatibility
and i'm also going to talk about how
i've been using it for work because i'm
actually just a regular old architect
during the day in the end i'm going to
give my thoughts on whether having a
convertible laptop with a pen actually
helps with my workflow or if it's just a
novelty by the way this is a sponsored
video but as usual this is a hundred
percent my own personal honest opinion
is it gonna be good is it gonna be bad
who knows
[Music]
hey guys welcome back to the channel if
you're new here my name is dami and i'm
a licensed architect in beautiful
vancouver bc on this channel we talk
about architecture and design as well as
some tools and strategies that can help
us have more meaningful and fulfilling
careers in architecture
and sometimes that is our tech tools
let's face it convertible laptops or
touchscreen laptops have been around the
market for a while now
but i've never really found them to be
that useful
um i actually have a touch screen laptop
for my war computer but um i never ever
ever use it for that function and in
fact it's pretty annoying sometimes
because like i'd be showing something on
my screen
and like i would accidentally touch the
screen uh forgetting that it is a touch
screen and just like it messes
everything up i think uh for it to be
really useful
um it actually comes down to the design
as well as the ergonomics i'm not saying
design cells but it really does so
these things are meant to solve two
problems at the same time the
spontaneity and the portability of a
tablet with the functionality and the
workability of a full-size laptop
but does it really do that
the hp spectre x360 has a pretty
spacious 16 inch ips 3k monitor with a
resolution of 3072 by 1920. i think the
monitor is actually really good um it's
got some really great colors the
brightness and the whites are really
well balanced and the resolution is
really good
and it's good enough to work with most
of the apps that i use pretty much on a
daily basis the resolution is definitely
a big factor for me because i work a lot
with apps like rhino revit or enscape
the keyboard is really comfortable and
the keys are very nice to type on
actually
even for very long sessions if you're a
night typer like me
rest assured it's backlit as well the
keys have a nice clicking sound which i
like because i can type really fast and
make it seem like i'm working really
hard just kidding there's also a
fingerprint reader on the lower side of
the keyboard but the main feature of
this tablet is definitely the 360 hinge
which lets you work in full tablet mode
and you can use the body of the laptop
as a stand for both vertical and
horizontal configurations and like our
phones the internal gyroscope adjusts
the screen according to the orientation
so you can use it when you're sketching
or typing or presenting or watching
youtube which i definitely don't do at
work and when you rotate a 360 and
you're using it like an ipad the
keyboard locks automatically to avoid
any unwanted typing and if you want to
put it down when it's in tablet mode
there's these little plastic feet that's
going to keep your tablet level the
spectre body is made out of metal and it
feels pretty sturdy and premium but
because of that it is a little heavy and
it's not as lightweight
like other tablets it comes with a pen
so you can draw and you can sketch you
can take notes and you can also do
this
or you can also do this
and you can also do this
actually i love using this pen because
it's got a pressure sensitivity and a
magnetic docking system so you can put
it on the side of the screen on the side
over here there's two additional buttons
for shortcuts like the eraser tool
and quick access to the contextual menu
to charge the pen you do need to use a
usbc cable but the battery lasts for a
pretty long time for a whole 30 days
without charging and when it's out of
battery there's a little light indicator
that's going to tell you if you need
more juice i'd love to see an option
where you can charge the pen wirelessly
or maybe changing the location of the
port so that you can dock it more
steadily while it's connected to a cable
connectivity has been a pretty sensitive
topic for me because it seems like every
new laptop out there is trying to get
rid of as much ports as possible to make
it slimmer and slimmer and slimmer i
understand like we're trying to push for
the wireless future
but like as a person working in
architecture
which first of all is very very slow
moving and second of all like freaking
requires so much transfer of data
between people
it's been a little frustrating to have
to connect to a dongle whenever i want
to like connect to a screen or to a usb
key for me it's a really simple thing
but it just drives me a little bit crazy
so i was quite happy to find that this
thing's got a sensible amount of ports
on the left side there's one full-size
usb type-a port which i find super
useful because honestly the vast
majority of the hard drives still rely
on usb ports this is a nice little
detail here the port's got a small
retractable angle which makes it less
noticeable and it helps smooth out the
edges of the laptop right next to the
usb port there is a tada
a full size hdmi connector again
super pleasant surprise for me because
uh very often
in order for me to connect my laptop to
a screen or projector
i have to carry around dongle every
single time and it's been super super
annoying for me
and having a dedicated pour it just
gives you that peace of mind that it's
gonna connect most places i go
and it's like one less thing i have to
worry about on the right side there's a
usb type-c port and there's a power
connector
and it has a micro sd card reader this
just makes the whole process of
offloading footage a lot faster
especially when you're on the go um i
would have preferred a regular sd card
reader since i use
mostly a sony dslr camera maybe next
time hp
what's also interesting is these two
additional ports on the edges of the
laptop
a 3.5 millimeter headphone jack on the
left side and additional usb type-c port
on the right side if you need to connect
multiple monitors there's good news
since the usbc ports are rated
thunderbolt 4 you can connect up to two
4k displays and what's better than
having one screen
two screens for me having a second
screen is a must whether i'm doing video
editing or working on revit
it's just a drastic improvement to my
workflow so it's like a no-brainer here
you can see the laptop connected to the
hp u28 monitor that i'm currently using
as a secondary monitor it's got a
27-inch ips display and has a visa mount
and lots of connectivity including usb-c
the full hd camera is right at the top
of the screen
and it's got an intelligent focus
tracking feature and it performs really
well in low light i was personally
really impressed with how it handles
your skin tones since you can use the
hinge to fold the laptop completely you
can take advantage of the 5 megapixel
photo camera to scan documents and even
take high quality photos for privacy
it's got a
physical shutter button that closes the
camera completely by pressing this
button
all right you nerds let's get into some
numbers the version that i'm using right
now is equipped with intel core i7
11390h and integrated graphics xc
it's a 4 core cpu running up to 5
gigahertz on turbo boost the cpu is not
the fastest on the market but it has
pretty good thermals and thanks to the
iris xc integrated gpu it performs
really well on most graphic applications
in fact the integrated gpu performance
is on par with dedicated graphics card
like the nvidia gtx 1060 ti but since
you have all the components integrated
into one soc the battery life goes well
beyond eight hours and depending on what
kind of tasks you're doing
it could reach
up to 14 to 16 hours so unless you're
looking for a mobile rendering machine
this chipset is capable of running all
the apps that you need including
archicad revit rhino etc
and even doing some like work on video
editing applications
in terms of software
first and foremost this machine runs on
the new windows 11 which is good news
for architects because um it really
means all the major software including
revit runs smoothly on this machine
without any emulation and of course as
an architect and as a creative
professional taking notes and drawing on
documents is part of my daily routine
and i do really like how this laptop
lets me switch pretty seamlessly between
these apps sketching and taking notes on
such a large display is pretty great
even the largest tablet on the market
doesn't go beyond 12 or 13 inches so
this 16 inch screen is kind of a game
changer since the spectre x360 is
running on windows 11 you can choose
over hundreds of sketching software the
best part is you're not just limited to
a dedicated tablet app like procreate
you can actually use the pen even with
tools like photoshop and illustrator or
any other app running on windows 11.
the laptop comes with a free version of
concepts but you can actually use any
other sketching app like fresco critta
sketchbook and more if you want me to do
a video where i test out all the
sketching apps and compare the prices
and the performance
let me know down in the comments i think
this is great especially for students um
because it just reduces the amount of
stuff you have to carry
i remember having to take around an
enormous amount of printouts and
notebooks when i was in school but with
this you can take notes you can
highlight the text and you can keep all
your notes organized you know one of the
reasons i'm so sure is because i had to
carry around so many freaking books when
i was in architecture school on top of
my laptop only if i had this i would
have been like two inches taller i did
take some time to test all the industry
standard architecture software like
revit autocad rhino sketchup grasshopper
they all work without problems if you
want a dedicated video for this uh for
these architecture software just let me
know in the comments there is of course
an active cooling fan base system that
turns on when the cpu is performing
heavy loads and it's very discreet
compared to other laptops i've used if
you need to transfer photos or other
documents from your phone this laptop
comes with a hp quick drop feature which
will let you transfer files between
devices wirelessly one of the most
common ways i use this tablet is to do
markups
we're constantly marking up our own
drawings or our consultants drawings and
before
we would have to print out like so much
paper
and i used to always feel so bad about
that because we just mark it up use it
and we just throw it away but now i mark
it up here and i just save it as a pdf
the other great thing is when you're on
a site visit i usually carry around
drawings and mark up the drawings
but i mean that's bulky first of all and
you can't really zoom in and out
and when you're moving so quickly
through your site review
your drawings can get really messy and
some of the information can get lost if
you don't remember to keep track of it
properly one of the downsides is that it
is quite heavy especially for a small
person like me it's a little too heavy
for it to be like as portable as a
tablet
and one of the things i wish it had was
a camera on the back
because something that i do um very
often especially when i'm on site is
take a photo
write notes directly on that photo and
you can't really do that with this i
think this is definitely more of a
laptop with drawing capabilities rather
than a tablet with laptop capabilities
if you know what i mean tablet for me
has very distinct functionalities and
use that help my day-to-day functions as
an architect and although this does do
that not having a camera function is
kind of a downside for me
talking about wireless connectivity we
also tried the hp envy 7955 color
printer and it's a printer scanner and
copier that lets you print from any
device wirelessly the setup was super
easy and it took less than three minutes
with the hp smart app and there's no
need for cables which means you can
place the printer pretty much anywhere
you want the quality of the prints are
amazing
and there is a dedicated drawer
dedicated
drawer drawer
drawer drawer for loading multiple types
of regular and photo paper it has a lcd
touch screen that makes navigating this
thing very easy
and i haven't wanted to break this
printer yet which is a good thing
because i have wanted to break many
printers in my life even though we work
mostly digitally whenever we have
meetings or design reviews we always
print
and i do it in my own design process as
well because i find that being able to
lay things out on the table is a great
way for visualizing things and it just
helps you see things differently my
homework space is full of inspiration
images of things i'm working on like if
i see something that i like i save it
and i print it out i find that the
process of manually aligning it and
processing elements is a really good way
to let your brain analyze and like
interpret it in a very logical fashion
sometimes i just want to turn off my
computer and just use these it is nice
to create some level of separation from
the computer personally the most common
method i use the tablet is when i'm
drawing over things so for example i
would find a photo online or i would
take a photo
on site and i sketch over it and so yeah
the printer and the tablet they work
pretty well together please make sure
you use fully recycled paper we can't
really afford to waste paper and
i'll leave some links in the description
for some good quality
fully recyclable paper options hp also
has a program called instant ink
where you can get a new ink cartridge
based on your actual consumption the
printer is a smart printer and it knows
exactly when it's running out of ink so
it'll go ahead and order the ink for you
when you're running out hp will also
take care of recycling your old
cartridges and they use the plastic to
produce new printers
so overall i think a convertible laptop
is a great tool for architects and
architecture students being able to
sketch markup drawings and use it as a
laptop it really improves your workflow
and it can really save you time
you know there's a reason trace paper is
the most commonly used tool for an
architect because it allows you to
sketch over a massing or image that's
already been created
and this is such a big part of most
architects design process
and this device basically lets you do
that without having to print out your
drawings so that's probably one of the
most important real life uses for this
machine i do most of my rendering on the
cloud now
or we outsource it so rendering
horsepower is not really a major concern
for me if it's not for you either i
think the hp spectre x360 is a really
good all-rounder that you can take into
consideration your laptop will be of
course your main point of reference for
research and creative work and and
having a flexible device that can adapt
to multiple situations
i think is pretty essential that's it
for this video thanks for watching till
the end let me know your thoughts about
convertible laptops and lastly if you
have any suggestions on laptops or tech
that you want me to look at just leave
it in the comments i will look into that
remember to like and subscribe to watch
more architecture content like my video
series about my thesis journey or how i
found my research topics i also have a
monthly newsletter where i share
insights and some tips and tricks so if
you want to stay updated i'll leave the
link in the description
alright i'll see you in the next video
bye
[Music]
you